we are not fighting men can take the
bounty off my head I am NOT one of the
fattest men I'm searching for service on
behalf of her kouf good
I am servos mighty harbour master of
size forced to hide on my own docks why
Seaford - after you that dog he's
strangling the whole town taxes us to
death he burnt my cousin's farm that's
right I've been doing what I can
helping people hide their imports and
exports what see fit who does not see he
cannot tax and he figured it out his men
they did my business on my house but I
hid my records on my felucca if I
haven't found my boat yet they soon will
I'll see what I can do
my felucca is tied up at the size dogs I
would refer to have it back in one piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you needn't hide any longer I secured
your felucca your documents are safe you
saved my felucca here take this as a
small token of thanks you have made
things better here
you clearly have people who are willing
to help you out service why don't you
take on Sofia - Sofia - is too powerful
too greedy he knows there is no one
strong enough to stop him we are not
fighting men safer - surrounds himself
with soldiers his base at fort Nikki who
is guarded with ballistic fool that I am
I helped him import them
maiya moon watch over you
[Music]
[Music]
Hamas's yes fresh cockles and mussels
today my name is Mike I come from her
coof he needs your help as a friend of
Jessica I'm listening
since Jessica was killed a goof needs a
trusted agent to Shepherd people out
from under offenders watch dead you and
how Cooper out of touch
Jessica's to puff to be held by savetti
she escaped the fibrin what where's she
back on the river
she took her felucca loaded with
supplies to the people she sheltered
she's taken a dangerous route to the
southwest pasture hippopotamuses to
avoid surfeit whose eyes if you follow
the calls you'll find her
[Music]
[Applause]
hyah I'll wear you blasted River Kinkaid
lake calls let me drive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you called
byuk good to meet you by AK I am Jessica
how did you end up here I got lost
sailed the wrong way I would not call
avoiding offenders patrols the wrong way
what do you know if they're fed - how
cool believed you are dead but you
escaped you need you back help me get
these supplies to my village there are
many depending on me
and we will talk
how do you know how cook I was sent to
him by a man to whom I am pledged I
believe we are working towards the same
end well her cough is a great man
the Esaias is a region of
self-proclaimed great men but her crew
has a good heart
he cares for his people and his city yes
he protects them from cowards like the
Scarab as a victory
I have smuggled many families like poor
way nice in a son out of size to keep
them safe
those who have tried to refuse it there
too he has bad day you got courageous to
protect families that are not sacred
if you say
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you said I hide them in my village
until we can arrange a caravan to get
them beyond the desert
hence the food and medicine I bring how
did you survive that that you saw just
brought me to 40g where they burned and
tortured me but I spat in their faces
when they thought to me broke and I by
the gods said to has come
no no a pen - and when it was men are
burning every Jesus
stay here let me take care of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once again drop it
did you hear that yes
pain - oh by the guards you are still
alive I will not leave you here
you
it may be untouched please help me bring
pen - of course I will take you
[Music]
[Music]
time is up
thank you for Pentos life I did nothing
that you would not have done he owes his
life to you this is not the end of it
however no those dogs still hunt for the
prick Master I will go to Haku we must
find a way to peel Suketu out of his
shell and deal with I cannot bring your
people back from the what but I will
help you avenge your village
[Music]
and nothing
time to die
[Applause]
continue
[Music]
gestures piano
[Music]
fight this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that takes care of sapatos eyes
[Applause]
[Music]